There are many ways to make networking contacts.
LinkedIn, which now has 170 million people worldwide is an excellent resource,...
...so try to use LinkedIn as a proactive research tool.
Join groups, connect with people.
So the best way to keep up with your contacts is to conduct a series of informational meetings.
Ideally, these would be face-to-face in person meetings, 20 to 30 minutes.
What you're doing is you're not asking for a job, but you're trying to uncover needs.
It's also important to develop a professional introduction.
This is a brief, concise introductory message that markets and promotes you.
It basically has three components.
You're stating your name,...
...your role, perhaps you're a student, you're a professional,...
...your career interest, what you have to offer and most importantly, next steps.